ils ont troqué le soleil et les plages
de floride pour ceux ci de nombreuses
nombreuses sont forcés de migrer plutôt
prévu vers la résidence estivale s'est
appuyé quétin parce qu'on a on a su
qu'il y avait certaines compagnies
d'assurance qui ne couvrait pas pour ça
il faut puis on sait pas d'enseigné ou
simplement de se taire en camping a
devancé son ouverture
en plus d'accueillir ces résidents
réguliers les propriétaires ont trouvé
de nouveaux espaces pour ceux qui
souhaitent s'isoler ici plutôt que de
traverser le québec pour rejoindre leur
domicile quand yariv ben nous on se
protège
ils rentrent pas dans le bureau on
essaie de donner des trucs essentiels je
suis arrangée avec l'épicerie du village
ils viennent me porter du stock puis je
crée pas de le faire des commandes pour
éviter qu'ils sortent du gameplay au
domaine le dauphiné les espaces publics
sont fermés par mesure de prévention
on demande aussi aux clients de
respecter les mesures de quarantaine
malgré tout certains résidents craignent
que le camping devienne un terrain
propice à la propagation du virus
les gens coup de poing non ceux qui
n'ont pas pas c'est eux qui sont
dangereux
nos voyageurs qui reviennent ici aucun
pays il y en a beaucoup qui n'ont pas
compris ce que ça voulait dire et puis
pour nous autres comme moi socialement
ça me fait de la peine au moment où on
demande à tous et chacun de rester chez
soi de nombreuses nouvelles sont encore
sur les routes pour regagner le québec
entre un autre et caution mais on sait
jamais qui est devant nous il faut faire
attention mais c'est sûr que ya toujours
un creux et orientaux sol suzanne par an
fait partie d'un convoi qui devrait
arriver lundi
mais les inquiétudes ne s'arrêteront pas
là c'est le chemin du retour peut
s'avérer long la route vers la sortie de
cette crise sanitaire elle demeure
encore largement inconnu ici pierre le
gagnons radio canada hemingway